hey everyone what is going on the mcu is
just massive right now isn't it so many
great things are unfolding i am excited
i'm pumped you've got daredevil you got
kingpin into the mcu now from the
netflix series but yet spiderman no way
home has leaves us with so many
questions after the movie
some of us understand it some of us
don't i'm gonna post some of those
questions here
and let me know your thoughts and if you
have any answers for them or any
questions that you guys have as well and
let's see if we can figure that out
together so with that let's get down to
some of the questions we have about
spiderman no way home after we have
watched it here are the top 10 questions
we have after watching spiderman no way
home okay let's go to the first one here
if the world forgets peter parker
what about the systems does he have a
birth records digital records what
happens with that um no bank account is
he just like a ghost
now here's very something very
interesting that i caught in the movie
maybe some people have caught it some
people didn't now he had a ged book
obviously that is you know
uh not the same as a high school diploma
so we had a gd book in one of his moving
boxes on top of that that means
he didn't graduate high school per se so
he took the ged
so high school doesn't have records of
him because the way i see the spell
which is a little bit confusing to some
is that the spell only erases uh the
minds of those who know that peter
parker is spider-man and since the whole
world knows that peter parker's
spider-man the whole world doesn't is
wiped clean and he's a ghost so but it
remains to be seen about digital records
and other records out there so
i think that may be the case but i'm not
too sure love to hear your thoughts on
that number two
who has ownership of all the stark tech
now i mean he had he had the glasses he
had the suits
now i know that the suit and the glasses
obviously recognize peter parker as the
owner
but does
friday now not recognize him at all
and
is that tech just null and void i mean
we did see him sewing his own suit
obviously it's a new design and
everything else is he going back to the
basics or will the stark tech uh is it
still available for him to use remains
to be seen number three is there an
uncle ben in the mcu this was not really
discussed we know about aunt may but did
she ha was there a ben was there an
ex-husband
was there somebody
that
maybe peter knew or didn't know because
when he had the conversation with the
other two peter parkers the uncle ben
thing really didn't click for him it was
only aunt may so this is interesting
could this open up another relationship
for peter parker to have and the newer
spider-man films an uncle ben that
actually does live since ant may sort of
replace that
very interesting uh topic what do you
guys think on that how powerful is
doctor strange now here's the thing that
kind of got me in terms of no way home
doctor strange is supposed to be the
sorcerer's supreme so to speak and of
course yeah he did give the title away
to you know to wang whatever the case
may be as he mentioned earlier but
he's still very powerful but you know
spider-man pretty much had his way with
doctor strange in the mirror dimension
relatively easy uh which is a little bit
odd and he was stuck in there for 12
hours so how strong is doctor strange
how powerful is he or did they just sort
of
you know
reduce his his strength and power to
make way for the introduction of the
other spider-man and to have that own
storyline and no way home so i hope they
sort of clear that up because they are
really um
kind of back and forth with doctor
strange and one more thing a little off
topic can they fix dr strange's hair
piece i mean
it was fine in the first movie and it's
getting progressively worse and worse
and worse it's almost becoming comical
it's like
dude can you not i mean you're marvel
studios you have a lot of money can't
you find a really good hair piece for
benedict cumberbatch and keep it because
he doesn't need to change his hair i
mean we all know it's got gray and it's
got kind of a pompadour look to it he
doesn't really need to change it but
every movie it's looking faker and faker
and faker anyway so the villains who
returned to their own universes that are
rehabilitated now what happens to them
do they die there do they live their own
life i mean what continues to go on
because you know part of the timeline
that we sort of understood through loki
is that things have to happen you know
if someone dies they have to die and if
they don't then that changes the
timeline it changes
history it changes everything so what
happens in this regard did it really
change
everything no matter what spell doctor
strange put into the mix very
interesting thought what do you guys
think on that all right guys before we
go any further here's a quick message
from our sponsor logitech here geek
culture audio is a huge part of our
daily lives both work and play so what's
our choice of headphones well meet the
logitech g435 lightspeed wireless gaming
headset it lets you listen to all the
rich sounds from your music videos and
games across pc console and mobile while
sporting some popping vibrant colors
not only that it weighs just 165 grams
which means sometimes you'll even forget
that you're wearing it with a robust
battery life of 18 hours you can enjoy
your gaming sessions for prolonged
periods of time for more details head
over to logitechg.com
now charlie cox is daredevil now we know
that he was part of the netflix universe
he's now into the mcu how does that work
are we gonna see you know kristen ritter
as jessica jones we're gonna see mike
coulter as luke cage are we gonna see
you know john bernthal as punisher are
they gonna come into the mix and if they
do how's their storyline gonna be i mean
they may be playing the same characters
or this you know but
is something radically different or are
they going to keep to that lineage of
the netflix universe so to speak but
just take bits and pieces and bring it
into the mcu you know that's going to be
a very interesting journey for all this
you know i mean loki we have variants
and so forth but are these variants or
how they're going to treat it i don't
know
it could be confusing or just could be a
really simple transition it remains to
be seen but i have a feeling we may see
this in episode 6 or get an idea of how
it will go in episode 6 of hawkeye now
we got to talk about ned because
ned
has some magical powers or has some
abilities we saw this in no way home and
it was interesting this sort of like
escaped my mind initially when he was
walking into dr strange's home and he
did say oh my grandmother said our
family has magic and strange sort of
brushed it off but when he had uh
strange's ring he's
able to open up the portals
i mean he obviously couldn't close it
but he was able to open it up and
remember how to do it relatively easy
so is there something about ned that we
don't know is he gonna become a villain
will he become you know part of
uh you know
the brew that uh or a part of you know
dr strange's universe i mean
what's gonna happen with ned
that might be a very interesting story
going forward of course we know he you
know in the comics becomes sort of a
villain hobgoblin but
will he
be somebody different
will they change it completely
who knows so the alien symbiote as we
know it knows that spider-man exists
right and even though eddie brock and
venom were sort of
vanished into their own universe in the
extra scene of spider-man no way home
what happens to this now does marvel
have access to venom can they use venom
in the mcu or is it still a sony
property
my guess it's still a sony property and
it went back to its respective universe
because
maybe they will use a venom or not now
they did say sony did say that marvel
did say that they can share characters
if and when so this might be something
that we see in the future venom coming
over to the mcu or vice versa
but it does pose a big question how does
venom now fit
into this new world
uh
very interesting and i know a lot of you
are very excited about venom being in no
way home unfortunately he's not in the
main movie but he's in the post-credits
scene what are your thoughts on venom
and his integration into the mcu or not
love to hear from you guys on that now
in terms of the other spider-man they
had a conversation and no way home about
the avengers right and this was sort of
that moment where they couldn't work
together and tom holland's peter parker
was saying look i worked with the team
the avengers and you know neither toby
maguire nor andrew garfield's peter
parker knew what that was
so in their own world is there no such
thing as the avengers are they solo acts
just living in new york city
or
is there another group that they're just
not belonging to i don't know that'd be
interesting to find out and how that
integrates into the whole thing because
if you would think about it in
multiverses if there's an avengers in
one universe would there be a somewhat
of an another avengers in another
universe right you would think there
would be or not
we don't know or is that because they're
part of the sony world
and sony's world has no mention of
avengers
it could be interesting to find out how
that unfolds so those are some of the
questions that we have in regards to
spider-man no way home let us know some
of the questions you guys have in terms
of the movie if you've already watched
it now if you haven't of course
watch it check it out i mean the movie
is a really good movie yes there are
some plot holes into it yes there are
some things that work and don't work and
i have a feeling there is a much
larger film that remains to be seen
that's probably been cut down in the
editing room and maybe they'll release a
director's cut or a uh a special edition
cut that's even longer because the
movie's already quite long but i have a
feeling there's much more in depth that
they left out for the sake of timing and
for pacing love to see that cut if it
ever exists anyway let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below
like always follow us on facebook
subscribe to us on youtube thank you so
much for the support of this channel we
really appreciate it and we will chat to
you soon take care
you